okay thank you for the introduction you
know so yeah I'm going to present some
new techniques and results we get during
the last I don't know two years
something that with Kirchner and Keanu
food and every every of these techniques
aim at having a fast efficient and maybe
one day provable way of reducing module
lattices or so called algebraic lattices
okay so first of all a bit of context
and I would start this presentation by
going back to the roots and redefining
every basic object by manipulating so
lattices and the energy let's say well
known most well known reduction
algorithm which is lll okay so what is
this all about so support that we are in
the Euclidean plane r2 and we take two
linearly independent vectors in this
plane we are considering the set of
integral linear combination of points
spanned by these two vectors and we get
a very structured set of points in the
interspace which we call a lattice so it
has both an algebraic structure and the
metric structures the algebraic
structure is the fact that it's a
subgroup of the euclidean space so why
that because you can really subtract and
add vectors and remain in the structure
and why it's why they're metric part is
because it's a discrete set of the space
so that you don't have two points which
are arbitrary close to one another okay
and then you have a natural way of
encompassing the density of the lattice
let's say and this notion is the co
volume or volume of the lattice which is
given by the volume of the fundamental
parapet edges which is generated by the
bases so then you could say okay but if
I give you another basis of the lattice
then the shape of this of this body of
this party people it's changing so that
maybe the volume is changing in fact
it's independent of the basis and so
this intrigue is this intrinsic
intrinsic invariant of the lattice is
give you a first question then if I take
my large bases here how can I retrieve
their first one two nice short and
orthogonal one may be your first first
idea is to use the longest vectors that
you hear - it's a short effect of Z - to
reduce the longest one here so what do I
do
I draw the line which is spanned by the
short vector and get through the second
one and I would take the smallest
element in the coset which is just here
okay I have new basis which is somehow
better and then I just repeat the
process so I draw the line and I take
the smallest element in the cassette and
I retrieved my initial basis okay so if
you want to write a natural algorithm
from this simple process you need to
find AK formulas for what I did and this
can be really computed from the
orthogonal projection so if I take my
short vector to be W Mellon vector to be
V I often got a project V over the line
spanned by W I round it so that I can
stay in a lattice because as I said the
only point which can reach are the point
with integral in your combination of the
basis so after rounding I subtract and I
get a new vector which is smaller than
the initial one okay so we should write
that down as the code basically you
retrieve the so-called
ghost-like contradiction and which is
just here so this is like this find the
smallest element in the coset part and
this is the continued as long as
something is happening so if you look at
the properties of the output basis from
this algorithm you can prove by just
looking at the girl here that the first
vector is necessarily smaller than
second one and that unit you have a
condition on the inner product of the
two vectors
this is just the fact that this quantity
should be zero if you are doing nothing
okay from that you can prove that U is a
short short as vector of the world
lattice so a vector with the smallest
norm among all possible norms
and from that you can also prove that
the norm of the first vector u is
smaller than a constant so here 4/3 x
security this is for dimension 2 in more
in a more general thing in arbitrary
dimension you still have this same kind
of theorem here which is Minkowski 2m
for the first minima which I said that
if I take a letter from B basically I
can find a vector which is roughly of
the size of the resize koval you so here
it's 1 over D for homogeneity reason and
there is kind of small constant here and
dimension to each for father in either
turn dimension can twist quadruped
okay so I know from Inca theorem that a
short vector unnecessarily exists okay
program is that from a compositional
point of view it's hard so it's not
really interesting if you want to play
with this vector actually
hopefully in 82 Lance Rollins ran lavage
address this question and proved that
there exists a polynomial time algorithm
that will retrieve a small vector in any
Euclidean lattice but you can't find in
point of atoms or short this one you
will find the shortest one up to
approximation factor and Z the arrow you
are meeting on it is something
exponential in two dimension so before I
explain you how you can we treat this
result and try to generalize it or let's
just speak about some funny application
of this theorem first one is the so
called similar news they haven't seen
approximation which is a general a
generalization of the die inferencing
approximation program I give you a bunch
of reels awry
and I will ask you to find a bunch of TI
and 1 in Q such that the area
approximately is well by CPI over Q so
this is kind of the general problem I
mean dimension 1 sorry this problem can
be can be solved by a continuous
fraction expansion but you can't do that
multiple time because the qubit not be
the same but you can solve that with a
little bit in the same idea you can find
minimal polynomials of some algebraic
numbers instead of having a bunch of
random a right here you can just take
the power of an algebraic number
and then using the dualities of the one
here you will be able to retrieve a
polynomial that vanishes at all from
that you can do polynomial factorization
over the rationals and most maybe most
importantly for this workshop you can do
a lot of crypt analytical work using LRL
so you can solve knapsack problem in
certain regime you can solve everything
for some public exponent and of course
when some crypto system are based on
lattices as their base core object you
will attack these problems using lattice
production so usually in this kind of
schemes the secret key is kind of short
vector or or something related to a
short vector in the lattice so finding a
short vector will help you to
pre-existing and last but not least the
ll is algorithm is also used in many
many algebraic number theory algorithm
in number theory algorithm because you
can use it to control the size of
elements during computation your void
blow-ups in in the size of what you are
computing each neurons to be used to
compute some normal forms and it's very
useful for some ideals computation so
it's a very basic building tool of
algebra of algorithmic number theory ok
so now a bit of the ideas that leads to
this algorithm so if you take a lattice
of from D then you take a basis of this
letter lattice let's say V 1 P D and
this basis is yielding filtration of the
lattice so what it is is you start from
the 0 vector then you can seriously 1
dimensional sub lattice which is spanned
by V 1 the first vector of the basis
then you do the same lambda 2 will be
sub lattice of run to spanned by the
first two vectors and so on and you get
an increasing chain of sub lattice
starting from 0 to the wallet okay why
is it useful what you can do is to give
a bit of conjugation on how good this
basis is from from the idea of the cover
you might introduce a bit earlier and
what you do is you take the filtration
at for each point H sub lattice of the
filtration you consider as the logarithm
of the co volume of this sub lattice
so basically what you what you what you
obtain is a vector of
rial which is in encoding somehow the
relative densities of these sub lattices
of the filtration okay this is just way
of having a bit of great on this
filtration okay and then if you want to
act on this filtration the only thing we
knew from what I explained before is the
Gauss algorithm for reducing wrong to
lattices so what we are going to try is
to act on the filtration using the
Gaussian code and what we can do is for
instance at index a we can auto any
project or equivalently takes a quotient
of these sub lattices here by what is
before him we'll get a quotient of long
- and it's from - last sub lattice can
be reduced using Gauss algorithm so we
apply it sense since we are working in
the quotient or in the projection just
to leave the vector but we can do that
and we replace the newly found vector in
the basis and so what is happening of
course we acted or locally on the proof
and profile here so we changed the value
of the degree in one point and what's
interesting is as a decrease and new
degree is smaller than the older one so
all in all we use this Gauss reduction
as a local tool over the filtration to
densify get okay so now we have this
nice little tool that acts point wise on
our situation
so if we want to go from local to global
we need to have a strategy to ought to
have an order of use of this Gauss
algorithm to fully reduce the bases and
maybe the simplest one is to start from
the beginning of the basis here and then
start producing so I would you see as a
first two vectors and there we get a
short vector
okay then what do i do i just shift
things and i will reduce a projection of
the second and third vector okay
newly found a new vector here and i can
continue like that but maybe at one
point there was a new vector i found
could interact which what with what is
before could be used for decreasing the
profile space so I just go back from one
step and reuse it okay and then I will
go up again again and again
and maybe there is some new vector newly
found that will be used to perform a
reduction of home watches before and I
just go back okay and then I will go up
and eventually can prove that I will
reach the end of the basis this is
nothing more than T L algorithm so more
precisely if we speak in algorithmic
term watch whether main tools we use to
perform this global reduction so one of
them is a QR decomposition which assert
that if I take an invertible matrix i
can write it as a product of an
orthogonal part and an upper triangular
one and why is it related to this
filtration thing because linear algebra
the encompassing a filtration
encompassing a flag is just nothing but
I thinking a triangular matrix so having
this QR decomposition is how to make a
link between this abstract object which
is a filtration and let's say practical
object which is a metric so working on
this Airport is nothing more than
working on the filtration or
equivalently it's like working on the
crab-fishing vectors and another tool we
used with our thing it is a size
reduction which is a kind of a
discretized process which mimics the
gram-schmidt orthogonalization of of a
bunch of vectors and the size reduction
is very important as it controls the
size of it coefficients and it avoids
blow ups and it helps to have a put
another magician okay a bit of
complexity now if we look at the
original release of control and Srinivas
you can prove that this llll algorithm
is running in a Big O of something into
the power of six in the dimension and
something a cubic in the bit size okay
if then you are computing if you are
computing exactly and this is what is
done here you are manipulating a lot of
fractions and numerator tomatoes are
increasing are going increasingly fast
growing and then you could think to use
floating point representation to against
perhaps in this computation of internal
values and milestone in that direction
was reached by infinite still in 2009
where they proved that you can reach no
you can reach quasi linear bound in the
bit size and no more still a more
recently proved that you can prove you
can use a recursive strategy on the
round to reduce dimension to reduce the
Serena's the complexity in something
which is quasi party candidate mentioned
and which is the quasi linear in the bit
size okay remind us of that which is
kind of the state of the art for lll
complexities okay so this was formally
land and from Euclidean lattices so now
a bit of algebra because like to talk is
speaking about algebra and let's see how
we can generalize this Euclidean
lattices to a more exotic context so
let's take a number field which is a
finite field extension of the field of
rational two we can be realized as a
polynomial cochon so Q of x over the
ideal generated by Soompi okay in this
field you have a very neat an
interesting ring which is a ring of
integers it's a set of field elements
which are unrelated by some monic
polynomial with coefficient in Z okay
abstract that I claim that this is a
generalization of the usual integers in
the following sense if you compute the
ring of integers of field Q itself and
you will retrieve Z because you just if
you take like an element let's say alpha
and Z you consider the polynomial X
minus alpha and Z and it's monic and
it's make your elemental fanship
a bit more generally if you take she
takes the I root and you are joint it to
Q then you will you will compute the
ring of it I drove this quadratic
extension which is your Phi the ring of
the Gaussian did and you do the same
with change a here sorry you will the
third root of assume there is a
primitive salute opportunities and you
will find the so-called eisenstein
integers
okay so how is this related to lattices
actually so I thought that a Euclidean
lattice was a descriptor group of the
Euclidean space it's what's the
definition I use in fact you can rewrite
that in more let's say algebraic way and
things at a nuclear lattice is a
free/busy module or fine a trunk with
something which encompasses symmetric
which is a quadratic form on the ambient
space okay so if you represent that in
matrix way it's nothing more than taking
the basis and the basic coach is a basis
element can be written with integral
elements okay so like freezy module is
not symbolic something which looks like
a vector of space but with base field so
base ring I know you could say okay but
you just said that there is a
generalization of the ring of integers
which is a way of the usual integer
which is a ring of attainder of a number
field so let's just plug this
generalization in our definition of a
lattice and we will just replace the
freezie module by a free ring of each
end result of something module of final
rank and out with something which is
encompasses a metric and from a matrix
point of view we just replace bases
represented by matrices with Z
coefficient by matrices with coefficient
in or L element of the field okay the
question is what is this inner product
on this crazy space in fact we have a
natural way of giving namiseom structure
on this kind of object and we do it by
looking at the embeddings of your field
into the complex numbers you have the
degree of the field number of them and
you can just tag them big vectors this
will embed all your field in a product
of art with certain power C to a certain
power which is animation space you have
a nice metric on that so you can pull
back the metric here and so if you write
the formula you will get something very
readable okay so maybe just let forget
but that is just to show you that you
definition of lattices yeah the tension
products in Oh L yeah so that implies
that R has an oh well actually yeah it's
not in fact it's not a big deal because
like you can always see you can always
well is always a full wrong see module
so there is no problem of that and it
since you can use the embedding you can
directly write the action as you want
into our because here like you have this
I said yeah many are meeting in art
projects see of the meetings and you can
just split them into a real part and
imaginary part so you have a reelection
somehow I increased new dimension okay
oh just just a quick example so now is
that we have the matrix structure we can
just represent the example I just gave
you earlier so for the Gaussian integers
if you write down the matrix a in your
product you see that one and I should be
orthogonal so you can represent the
Gaussian integer as a square lattice and
for the Ascension integers you retrieve
actually see of the exactly lattice so
this is like two very simple example
actually of diamond of Rank 1 algebraic
lattices rank 1 over the field but wrong
too over the integers
I'm confused with the Oh El module
structure on our is if what you do is
basically you just use the embedding and
you complete it since you are Johan
video and check your embedding as a new
complete with our I mean this one one
one and when one is fixin basically the
structure is can be just written down I
mean I I can show you the writing at the
end if you want then it's just just like
pure pushing of the of the so yeah I
mean how can we reduce this object since
now we have a natural emission so Jones
is algebraic objects the question is how
do we reduce reduce set okay a bit of
like a fan of what we are going to
explain here it's bit of an
impressionistic view of everything not
going in terms of details so okay first
of all the basic idea in capacity lll
was to reduce the search for an approx
element to an approximate key in
dimension two so we are going to do
exactly the same here but for modulus vp
and we are so using the QR decomposition
once again because this is what we are
using for nuclear then lattices okay but
the problem is that if we just stop
there we need an Oracle to solve this
wrong too small wrong two instances of
modulus VP so this kind of not
satisfactory if we want to implement the
algorithm not in exponential time I will
address this question just after partly
to that we are going to show that we can
use a recursive structure on the wrong
to have a parallel version of the
algorithm and of the reduction and we'll
have to control the precision so all of
this will give you a very fast LLL type
algorithm and from that we will be able
to address this question of the or occur
and we address it by using Rico stivity
over the base field so if we are if we
are taking a natural break that is over
an upper field and we have a subfield
somewhere here what we do is once I have
to reduce my small run to lattices I
will just descend this lattice super
subfield and Rick Rios over it so all of
this will need to be very carefully
controlled we need if I dissing at one
point I will need to lift another point
and this is a tricky part I will expand
on that and I will also show you that
you can leverage some specific elements
of the field which are calls you need to
to help reduce the precision and
therefore the global complexity and last
but not least we will try to leverage
something even more interesting for
mathematical point of view which is a
natural symplectic structure on the
upper field and from that we will see
that we can have a simplistic geometry
which is compatible with the subfield
ascent and we will try to beat the
number of swaps which are given by the
usual and in the analysis of a letter
okay this is a scary world
I should have the wick wick thing of Leo
but don't worry see that is pretty
actually pretty crazy simple and from
that we can have very neat application
and we implemented all of this algorithm
so we can break some fhc over the
integer we can say we can break some
knapsack problems we can design your
faster gantry's it low implementation
and we can also break some
overstretching through lattices so these
are the applications okay so now I'm
going to get a bit into the details of
these funds so about this first
prediction of rosy it's the idea that we
can use recursion over the wrong to
parallelize everything okay so of course
we are still working with the QR
decomposition of the lousy of the matrix
so every single tension with recap so
LLL but we are not going to do this back
and forth sequences of small rank two
reduction what we are going to do
instead is to parallely reduces wrong to
sub lattices but at the same time
and we are not we are not taking
overlapping sub lattices but just the
one which our Negros okay this is a
first type of reduction but now you
might say okay but what about these two
vectors here and here they are not going
to to act on themselves what we do then
is just to shift the way we're reducing
them and we're releasing all Z crossed
neighbors and so we are doing it again
and again from that we are still
reducing locally so that is by sequences
of wrong to reduction but we're doing
that in a parallel way okay now actually
so surface this this is no no it has
been it can be found in a purple villa
in 91 and then ruin 93 then maybe
subsequently in other paper but I think
the two first one where these ones so
this is for the only and if anything is
that if you apply a round of this local
reduction on you can look at what is
happening on the profile space so
previously I said the Gauss prediction
was just acting locally on one point of
the profile space and decreasing it okay
now since were acting everywhere we are
doing something on the full profile
space and what we do is just to actually
average each value at one iteration and
this is a remaining scent of a very
famous equation of in physics which is
the heat equation because what we're
doing is at each its increment of time
we are averaging the values over the
world space this is applying the
laplacian of a writer at each step so
here is for instance a solution of the
heat equation when you are starting from
an inside distribution looks like that
and what is interesting is that the
character is characteristic evolution
time of this kind of equation is
quadratic and here in the discrete case
we still have the same we still are
looking at a never done evolution a
process which is which will have a
characterizing time which is quadratic
in the diameter of the space
diameter of the space is not
more than the size it's a number of
three months in my space which is D so
we are hoping some out who have
something which looks like this square
number of iteration okay this is the
first thing but actually if you look
more closely at what is happening you
can see that in all of this production
every operation is local this guys here
are not going to interact with these
guys here because there are far away so
we can't remark that now it's possible
to reach us on blocks instead of
directly doing small steps of reduction
and so we are taking a small number of
big blocks let's say four here then we
are splitting our basis for big blocks
and we are requesting exactly in the
same way in these big blocks so first
block here we're going to reduce using
the same techniques as before inside
block similarly we are going to reduce
using here here here and then we do
exactly the same as before we are using
shifted blocks so we only have three now
and we are reducing inside all of these
blocks okay and we are doing that again
and again until nothing more happens so
now if you reduce the analysis with this
kind of heat equation you are not
quadratic in the diameter of the space
but you are quadratic in the number of
blocks and since the number of blocks is
a small constant well you are the number
of rounds which is now a big constant
and no more something which is quite a
ticking so now if you just look at a
natural city from the actor
implementation this is a gram-schmidt
vector which is in fact related to this
profile space this is like what is
happening so we started from maybe a we
we started started from you do things
reducing the central part recursively
here then we reducing recursive
recursively recursively and at one point
will start acting on the tails here and
here so this is exactly this it with
this evolution about doing in a
recursive manner and now if you look at
what is going on on the reduction from a
complexity point of view you can prove
that for well conditioned matrices you
can you ristic Li find a vector which in
the lll bounds in something which is
let's say G Omega B which is roughly a
constant number of
matrix multiplications this is your
ristic there is awesome heuristic to how
to have a grip on which precision is
actually needed at each step of the
recursion and we are not able to find
like real proof of then we needed this
heuristics but whatsoever the estimated
complexity looks like that and it's a
coherent with the experiments so this
was for the improvement of the lll
algorithm ya know it's related to the
authority to seek a path with the system
yeah yeah but see I mean I have this
yeah I have this condition on the on the
condition so now go back on the
algebraic parts and so as I said we are
going to use exactly the same ideas over
Z but here we are going to exploit
algebraic specificities of the field to
be able to pursue a reduction so we're
still working on this QR decomposition
everything is working fine at least told
us the other day like the formulas are
exactly the same the reduction can still
be done with this parallel structure
which just is just an abstract way of
reducing so it's the same now what about
the size reduction over the reals
basically the size reduction requires us
to do integral rounding because I said
it's the discretization of the ground
treat optimization at one point you are
rounding so you have to round over the
integers you cannot see more than the
sivb instance in dimension one if you
translate that over a number field
basically what you need is to find the
closest element in the ring of integers
so it's also an instance of CVP but if
your base ring is very large then you
have a very large instance of CVP and
then you're like okay I'm stuck actually
you don't need to do an exact CVP here
but you can choose to an a proxy VP so
just find something which is somewhat
close not so closest and actually
something very dumb surfaces for the
approximation factor are reaching it's
just that we were doing the code
was running because I told you you can
represent your number field as modular
polynomials and so you take your
polynomial and round each coefficient so
this is very dumb this is very bad but
this is plenty sufficient in our case
let's say we're done with the size
reduction with that actually there is a
small hack here we need to use the units
of the number field to decrease the
condition number of the of the matrix
everywhere so that we can lower the
precision and maintain well condition
matrices so I'm not going to answer that
it's like a necessary hug but so the
general strategy is now here you take a
tour of number field you take a module
over the number field so which look like
that okay then you are applying your
reduction from like you want to apply
solution the algorithm is asking you now
to reduce some projects is wrong to some
modules okay so now I have to reduce
that now I'm stuck I should use like an
Oracle which is solving this reduction
problem about this instance but what I
can do is I can descend this module
offers a sub field so I get a new module
which is exactly the same but viewed
over some some fields so this it's wrong
increased and it's increased by the
factor which is equal to the velocity
crib between the two and I have a new
instance of reduction in high room so I
can do the same and I can recursively
call the wall algorithm and now this
algorithm is tell me please reduce me
this kind of sub lattices okay but I
still don't know how to do it so what I
can do is to descend again over some
some field then do the same and the same
attack wall points I will descend in the
number field and I don't have an
arbitrarily I don't have an infinite
number of sub fields so at one point I
will I will go to the end of the tower
and the end of the tower is basically
reducing lattices over Z and I can do
that and then I will have to reduce some
wrong to project in modules over Z which
are just wrong to Euclidean lattices and
I can do that using Gauss algorithm or
if you want to be faster using show-
rhythm and so you will find some short
vectors you can use the short vector to
find the reduced basis and then you can
plug this everything back to some
whatever things find a short vector of
this lattice here lift it up find
shot Victor lift everything financial
basis and go back in the tour from the
exact same place where you where they
sent so you descend and then you lift
everything and this is the global
strategy of reduction Rick receive over
the wrong already so if you in strange
instance yes at that over number fields
basically over sorry cyclotomic field
basically you can reach a reduction
which is in all soft n square B where n
is a degree of your cyclotomic field
this is also your ristic we need some
heuristic to control the size of the
lifted elements so we can't get rid of
that directly and there is a small trick
here we don't have the exact same
approximation of lll but we have
something which is slightly worse which
is all soft n so we are faster than L ll
but the approximation faster is a bit
worse ok this is trade-off and last but
not least and for I will compute that we
can you we can go even faster using some
geometric structure on the field so what
is this basically I'm just going to draw
a small table which is giving you the
differences between the Euclidean space
and simply tick space Euclidean space is
beta key suspect we're living in like 3
whatever and the symplectic space is the
space where let's say physicist a living
because this is something from physic so
you take your real vector space and you
undo it with some symmetric bilinear
form and you know product nondegenerate
for that ok this is a usual way of
measuring angles and what you do for
gating is simply it expects you do the
same that you are adding 4 litres 4
litres like antisymmetric this is now
basically so this small difference will
make everything nice so you look at all
the linear transformation which are
acting on your space and you take only
the one which are presenting the inner
product so this is a definition of the
orthogonal group ok so you can do
exactly the same you can take the space
so is there a space so this is a group
of linear transformation which are
preserving the simplistic form this will
give
they simply kick space it's exactly
dependent of it okay and this orthogonal
group as is very nice why because from
any basis you can transform with the
gram-schmidt organization process your
basis into an orthogonal one and this
means that the gram matrix of this basis
will have this shape con matrix is the
matrix of the pairwise inner products so
for an orthogonal basis basically the
you are orthogonal to every other
vectors explaining the zeros and the
norm of each element in an optimal basis
is one so the matrix is an identity and
for simplistic spaces you have something
also nice which is called a mu basis and
it can be computed exactly in the same
way that you compute the orthogonal
basis but instead of having the identity
you will find something which is called
a double base which is a block matrix
with - and it changes it in the reverse
order so this means something
on the one hand assembly takes place
might be odd-even dimension okay
first remark because you are D in D here
so dimension is 2 D second remark is
that you have some interaction between
first vector and the corresponding last
vectors so you have ten wise like
interaction and how we can going to use
that so if you want to do the reduction
let's say of some lattice here this is
just elements elements
I'm reasoning an abstract way so if I
want to reduce it in the Euclidian case
I'm going to so look at your first
vector okay and then we use you reduce
the second vector using the first one
okay this is the first step of the ll
evolution its assembly TK is I will do
the same I will use the search I will
reduce the second vector using the first
one but since I told you that because of
this very specific structure I have an
interaction between this vector and
these vectors what will happen is that
from the rejection of that tectile can
get this one for free then I will push
through so in the Euclidean case that we
need to reduce the sub vector using the
two first in the assembly together we
need to reduce the subject or using the
first birds hack I will get this one for
free
then I cross you I cross through it was
true and I will reach the middle of the
basis so here I have reduced this part
of the basis I also have reduced this
part of the
into simply Takei's but using simply
kick symmetries I also get that one for
free
so I decrease the number of operation by
something a bit less than two okay so
now how we can we plug that in this
recursive strategy over the number field
so the first thing is okay I said I have
I have a simplistic form which helps me
to do the reduction so I need to find a
simplistic form here I need to find the
symmetries so I will just use a very
less economical simply kick form which
is the determinant form which is
basically the generalization of Joseph's
area between two vectors this is a
determinant this is a simplistic form
just give you symmetries already okay
I'm taking that then what I'm going to
do is trying to have the same structure
on the subfield so we need to define a
new symplectic form which have the same
properties as the form above and how I
can do I can do that I can do that by
finding a suitable suitable linear form
T and composite with my phone and I do
that at each step so that when I will
reduce recursively in the field I will
still have at each level some simply
click form to explode and so what we
want it's to have a compatibility this
is why when I say suitable if I take
wrong to module / 0 / field
I want that descent over the subfield
here which is of size of ROM to our is
also symplectic for so form I found here
so at each step basically I will I will
have for free
simplistic structures that will have the
number of of operation I have to do
since the tour here is not trivial I
will gain 2 at each level and so I will
have something in 2 2 z 2 2 Z hate
improvement and so if you look at what
it's giving more precisely than for
cyclotomic field we can have something
which is in a soft of n square minus
something
something is over here if you implement
that for very large bit size over
cyclotomic power of two you find
something here which which is in n to
the log three which is lower than N
squared and we still achieve something
with support summation facto slightly
worse than the regular eleven so
everything has been fully implemented
and so we made so full testing on that
so here are some practical result from
the implementation of this all of these
techniques actually so for not knapsack
like algorithm were able to reduce so
kind of old FH instances of dimension
like two thousand in something like
thirty hours we estimated the cost of
what could take FP LLL for this kind of
this kind of elements it's something
would take at something like 2,000 years
and then from the structure part or
using like this recursive structure of
our number fields basically we're able
to reduce ggh light 200 something 204
lattices with few thousands of bits in
something like four days which would
have taken something like a lot of time
using FP yeah and yeah so the platform
use was something with one only 28 Kos
with when terabyte of RAM and all of
this all of this implementation is
public or even thought is still a cover
concept so maybe you will have some
slight cover when using yet I don't know
but we will be happy to help if you want
to install it and please make sure that
you have a nice way of cooling your CPU
because it's kind of heavy computation
for specific instances yeah for like
this fh example it's in in fact of
security parameters of a she pepper was
teaching a little like algorithm break
the Stefan's out doing the parameters
like that of course it's not I mean it's
not big easy poor I mean you you yeah
yeah maybe maybe a world on that since
you're asking yeah this is exponential
approximation factor this is absolutely
not something which is big easy right it
just just to be some specific example so
maybe a bit yeah for the one minute left
I just speak a bit on like open
direction and open problems that I hear
so I said that we are using simplistic
structure to decrease the complexity and
but it increase the approximation factor
at the same time what we could do is try
to use to use more general geometric
structure not simplistic forms but
higher order symplectic form so we had
kind of technical issues and ceiling
working but not going to extend that and
I said that there were a lot of
heuristics so I said yeah we need to
control the procedure mean to control
the lift path everything needs your
esteem so having approved the fully
proved algorithm even if it's lower
would be very interesting at least from
a theoretical point of view and a way to
do that would be to not reuse free
modules but projective modules and which
means that we are not reducing copies of
the ring of integer but we are reducing
modules which are some copies of
fractional ideals okay
and the idea to do that would be to now
extend our lifting so these things that
take your small vector in a subfield to
see upper field I mean to extend that to
ideals we can use like techniques
inspired by Cohen but now you would look
we need not to compute these vectors but
to complete these ideals at every step
and this is costly actually and this
will become the bottleneck of the
algorithm and in fact what we could have
is to so since you can see your ideals
as lattices we can use the Egyptian
algorithm we are constructing to reduce
ideals and to have a nice way to
multiply them an efficient we're using
using reduction algorithm and from that
you would have
to cross reduce to cross recursive
algorithm one is the reduction algorithm
here one is the fast multiplication of
ideas and then the reduction we say a
please multiply misses I'd also say okay
but please reduce misses lattice and
this is across valuation at any point so
as a by-product of having a proved way
of reducing projects then you have a lot
of know different numbers that would
mean a billion I said okay I'll be done
drinking sorry okay sorry modules which
is supposedly very expensive do you
think you could generalize you algorithm
to the CG lattice and not just have an
exploitation of the structure depending
on the G you get of course the point is
do you have a quantum I can you click on
so to consume algorithms this is beating
the classical scene
it's a it's kind of the basically the
same as the regular way and I would say
okay no I'm cheating a bit but it's kind
of but I'm not sure I mean since you are
working in a quantum setting and not
sure if this is really gained a lot from
that this is also did a municipality
[Applause]